joe pesci it doesn't play around yeah  okay so i had a guy  stuart  uh an annoy you know how annoying this  dude is trump  told me that that's the most annoying  person he's met  so [ __ ] this is the dude that annoys  trump imagine how [ __ ] annoying you  gotta be when trump goes that guy's the  most annoying [ __ ] guy i've ever met  so he's orange and he's loud  and he's calling [ __ ] joe  pesky oh  and right around the putting green he's  like pesky the whole day  pesky this and joe goes hey listen  maybe you don't know  because maybe nobody told you but it's  not pesky [ __ ] it's pitch  and he goes hey take it easy pesky i'm  just busting the clothes oh wait i don't  know if you're busting my balls you  [ __ ] orange [ __ ]  and he goes i have melanoma and he goes  good i hope you die you [ __ ] horse  [ __ ]